اعرضت وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه جاني
تشيلين عن تفاؤلها بنتائج زيارتها للصين
رغم اعترافها باستمرار الخلافات معها بشان
قضايا عده من جانبهم مسؤولون صينيون الى
ما سموه بناء علاقات اقتصاديه تحكمها
قواعد عادله ياتي هذا بالتزامن مع دعوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لدعم التقارب مع الصين
لتعزيز الامن الاوروبي
اهلا بكم كان هذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الاسس التي بنت
عليها وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تفاؤلها
بشان مستقبل العلاقه مع بيجينا وما مدى
اتفاق الجانب الصيني مع هذا التقييم وما
مفهوم امن اوروبا الذي دعا الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى دعم التقارب مع الصين من
اجله ومن العقبات التي تحول دون ذلك في
الوقت الراهن
ومستقبل العلاقات بين الصين والغرب في ضوء
كل تلك المعطيات وما تاثيرات التقرب
الصيني الغربي على توازنات القوى في
العالم
[موسيقى]
اذا في ختام زياره استمرت اربعه ايام
وجاءت بعد اقل من شهر فقط من زياره اخرى
كان قد قام بها وزير خارجيه بلادها الى
الصين هي الاولى على مستواها خلال خمس
سنوات وصفت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جانيت
في ختام زيارتها للصين محادثاتها في بيجين
بانها خطوه اولى نحو استقرار العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه
التي يصفها مراقبون بانها من معارضيه تشدد
مع الصين اعربت عن تفاؤلها بشان نتائج تلك
الزياره رغم تاكيدها اثاره قضايا من قبيل
ما سمتها الممارسات الاقتصاديه الصينيه
غير العادله واجراءات بيجينا القسريه بحق
الشركات الامريكيه
على الجانب الصيني دعا مسؤولون الى بناء
ما سموه علاقات اقتصاديه تنافسيه تحكمها
قواعد عادله مع الولايات المتحده كما
اكدوا اسفهم ازاء ما وصفوه بالحوادث غير
المتوقعه التي اضرت بالعلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده
عرب نائب رئيس الوزراء الصيني اذا عن اسف
بلاده ازاء ما وصفه بهذه الحوادث غير
المتوقعه التي اضرت بالعلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده
وفيما بدات تاكيد لهواجس الغرب بشان
العلاقه مع الصين دعا مسؤول سياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
الى دعم المقاربه مع الصين من اجل ما سماه
تعزيز امن للاتحاد الاوروبي لكن بوريل
الذي اجلت الصين زياره له اليها كانت
مقرره الاثنين اكد في الجلسه الافتتاحيه
لمنتدى
السادس عشر في كرواتيا ضروره التخلص من
التبعيه للصين على المستوى الرقمي مثل ما
تم التخلص من الاعتماد على الطاقه الروسيه
بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
نيويورك من
مدير مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكي السابق
لشؤون الصين
وينضم الينا من بيجينا رونجو 1 الاعلاميه
والكاتب الصحفي ومن باريس ينضم الينا
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس اهلا بكم
جميعا وابدا معك
سيد زينس
وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه بدت متفائله اذا هذه
زياره التي قامت بها الى الصين ما اساس
هذا التفاؤل ما داعي تفاؤلها
[موسيقى]
ان احد الاسباب الرئيسيه لهذه الزياره
والناس
اكبر مسؤول امريكي قوته والنفوذه في مجال
اقتصادي وان مفتاح زيارتها وشاي الاساسي
في زيارتها انت اتعرف على اعضاء الوزاره
الجديده في الصين فقد تغيرت الصين في هذا
الربيع المسؤولين
المسؤولين عن قضايا الاقتصاديه والاقتصادي
في البلاد فاردت ان تشرح لهم ان الولايات
المتحده لا تبتعد عن الصين وانه الولايات
المتحده تود ان تكون هناك منافسه صحيه بين
مع الصين وانت كل علاقات قويه مع الصين
السيد رونج هو ان اهل الصين ايضا متفائله
هل تشارك وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه هذا
التفاؤل
طبعا الصين يعني
تتماسك بموقف انفتاح لتبادل وتعاون مع
جانب امريكي
يعني طبعا هذه الزياره يعني افضل من اعدم
عدم زياره وكذلك هناك الحوار بناء وحوار
صريحا ومباشر مع الجانب الامريكي
الصين يعني
تاملوا من الولايات المتحده تطبيق يعني
التوافقات التي تواصل اليها
البلدين في لقائه العام الماضي ويعني
السير في نفس الاتجاه مع الصين
بتعاون وكذلك مواجهه اتحاديه المشترك
اذا
بالطبع هي تطور ايجابي بعد مرحله توتر
شهدتها منطقه بحر الصين وبعد اقامه امريكا
لتحالف جديد سياسي وعسكري مع استراليا ومع
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه بهدف احتواء
احتمالات التمدد الصيني بسبب طبعا ازمه
تايوان وهناك تنافس اقتصادي كبير كما
تفضلتم
وهناك توقيت مهم ايضا هو الحرب في
اوكرانيا اذ ان امريكا واوروبا تريد ان
تثير تناقضات ربما بين بيكين وموسكو هناك
رغبه باظهار ان التمايز قائم
ويريد الغرب بشكل عام ان يسترد الصين ببعض
الامور مقابل شروط معينه وكل هذا بهدف
الصين عن روسيا ولو ان ذلك ليس طبعا
محتوما لكنه محاوله واظن اي تواصل هو افضل
من استمرار التوترات التي كانت وما زالت
قائمه هل تشارك دكتور زياد ماجد هذه
الفكره ان واشنطن تحاول استقطاب الصيني
الى معسكررها فيما يتعلق بحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا من خلال هذه الزيارات المتكرره
لانه قبل اقل من شهر كان هناك وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي في بجين
الولايات المتحده
متشوقه لايجاد طرق لتحقيق السلام في
اوكرانيا وتامل الولايات المتحده ان الصين
تلعب دورا ايجابيا في هذا المجال وقد قدمت
الصين مقترحه في بدايه هذا العام
وكانت بعض جوانب هان واقتراح لم ترى
الولايات المتحده انها بناها لكن فيها
جوانب ايضا بناءه مما ذلك التاكيد على
حمايه السياده وسياده وسلامه اراضيه
اوكرانيا وبالتالي نحن نتمنى ان نرى نحن
في الجانب الامريكي نتمنى ان نرى ان تلعب
بتلعب دورا اكبر في اقناع روسيا وبوتين
بان هذه الحرب العدوانيه وغير القانونيه
التي يشنها الروس روسيا يجب ان تتوقف
ولابد للقوات الروسيه ان تنسحب ويترك
الشعب الاوكراني يعيش بسلام وتوافق مع
جيرانهم الرسل يعني على ضوء الزيارتين
لوزير الخارجيه قبل شهر اقل من شهر ووزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه هل يبدو الموضوع او
المجال الاقتصادي او التقارب الاقتصادي
ربما اسهل من التقارب السياسي خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالمثال الذي ذكره قبل قليل الدكتور
زياد ماجد وهو موضوع اوكرانيا وحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا
طبعا الموضوع الاقتصادي والتبادل
الاقتصادي والتجاري يعني هو يمكن ان تحرك
التبادلات في مجالات اخرى فهناك اهتمام
مشتركه
لهذا التبادل التجاري والاقتصادي لان كذلك
هناك دعوات من الشركات الامريكيه
للتواصل والتعاون مع الصين وكذلك
ارشحتنا زياره متكرره لرجال الاعمال
الامريكيه الامريكيين
والاصحاب الشركات الكبرى العالميه
الامريكيه
ولذلك راينا ان زياره ديالي كذلك هو
التاكيد لدعم الحكومه امريكيه لتعود يعني
الشركات الامريكيه لان
ارتباط يعتبر كذلك كارثه للولايات المتحده
كذلك فلذلك
اقل من خلال هذه الزياره هناك التوافق
يعني حسب كذلك حسب مواصفاتها في
المؤتمر الصحفي صباح اليوم
فالعالم يعني يستطيع استيعاب التنميه
المشتركه للبلدين
[موسيقى]
يعني التعاون بدلا من المواجهه
اعتقد هذا يعني على الاقل بدايه بوادر
ايجابيه للاستقرار للعلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه لان
العلاقات الصينيه امريكيه مستقرا سيساهم
ليس في يعني لا يسوق لصالح البلدين فحسب
بل يثب لصالح جميع دول العالم ولكن رغم
ذلك هنا اذهب الى دنيس وسنتحدث عن البعد
الاوروبي مع الدكتور ماجد بعد زياد بعد
قليل هنا
الوزيره لم تخفي بعض
المخاوف قالت الوزيره الامريكيه وهي من
الداعين الى طبعا الى علاقات جيده مع
الصين لم تستطع في الواقع اخفاء مخاوفها
او مخاوف بلادها الامنيه من الجانب الصيني
ما هي المخاوف الامريكيه بالضبط او الخشيه
الامريكيه من الصين في ماذا تتعلق بالضبط
عده مجالات للقلق والخشيه اولها ان الصين
قد اصدرت
قراره او قانونا جديدا ضد التجسس والعلوق
العلاقات الخارجيه او الاجنبيه وفي
القانونين يبدو هناك تصريح ظني بان الامن
في الصين الان بدا يعني بانهم بانه لا
يستطيعون ياخذ اي رجل اعمال اجنبي ويضعونه
في السجن لاي نشاطات نحن رانا نشاطات
تجاريه مشروعه مثلا بحث عن البيانات
ومناقشات مع شركات واشخاص في الصين حول
طبيعه شركاتهم
والعنايه الواجبه التي تقوم بها الشركات
الامريكيه عند ان تقوم باستثمارات في
الصين ولكن نجد ان هناك بعض منع يحصل على
بعض رجال الاعمال الامريكان وبالتالي هذين
القرنين لدي مكافحه ايضا يؤثران على ذلك
وقد اعلنت الصين ايضا الان سيطره على
الصادرات على بعض انواع المعادن نحن لا
نرى عن ذلك يعادل الاجراء الذي اتخذته
الولايات المتحده للدفاع عن بعض مجالات
الامن القومي بل نرى ان هذا هو رد فعل
وانتقام وبالتالي فان الوزيره اثارت هذه
المواضيع نيابه عن الشركات الامريكيه على
الذين 690 مليار دولار من التعامل التجاري
مثلا شركات الثعبان وساربكس جون دير
وغيرها من الشركاتيه تعمل في الصين وهم
بحاجه الى بيئه تجاريه او عمليه امنه
ومنصفه وان الوزيره
توفي نفسها المخاوف الاوروبيه
اعتقد ان المخاوف الاوروبيه تختلف بعض
الشيء هناك 20% من واردات اوروبا تاتي من
الصين مقابل تصدير 9% فقط من الصادرات
واظهرت ازمه
ان جزءا من مكونات الادويه
والعديد من مكونات كل ما هو رقمي تكنولوجي
اساسي تاتي من الصين او من الهند بمعنى ان
اوروبا وهذا ما اشار اليه وزير خارجيتها
بدات مرتبطه كثيرا
بما تنتجه الصين وعليها ان تاخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار اذا ارادت توازنا في علاقاتها
كما ان الصين حضور في الحوض المتوسط عفوا
فقط
هناك حضور في الحوض المتوسط وهناك حضور في
دول افريقيه لاوروبا مصالح اساسيه فيها
وبالتالي تخشى اوروبا ان توترا مع الصين
يمكن ان يكون قريب حتى الى اراضيها بسبب
التنافس في اوروبا وفي منطقه
المتوسط اضافه طبعا الى المساله
الاقتصاديه وهي اساسيه جدا لكن اذا كيف
نفهم كلام مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل عندما قال
ان اودعى الى تعزيز الامن الاوروبي من
خلال التقارب مع الصين ما مفهوم الامن
الاوروبي من وجهه نظر بوريل والاوروبيين
حاليا المساله الامنيه طبعا مرتبطه بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ولا تريد اوروبا في
ظل هذه المرحله الخطيره بالنسبه اليها ان
يكون لها توترات مع عملاق اقتصادي ومع طرف
يستطيع ايضا ان يساهم بالتجسس بسبب
التكنولوجيا المتطوره التي يصدرها الى
اوروبا وبسبب الساحات التي للاوروبيين
مصالح فيها هو يشير بشكل اساسي الى الامن
الاقتصادي والى مساله مساله الاكتفاء
الذاتي الاوروبي التي لم تحققها بعد
القاره بسبب الارتباط العضوي مع بعض
القطاعات الاقتصاديه الصينيه اراد من جهه
اظهار ضروره تعزيز العلاقات وهذا مطلب
اوروبي تجاهها واشنطن لتقليص التوتر في ظل
الحرب في اوكرانيا اي لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك اكثر من جبهه في نفس الوقت وهناك
مساله الامن الاقتصادي والسياده
الاقتصاديه الاوروبيه التي اصبحت اكثر فاك
موضوعا في العلاقات الدوليه نعم لكن
رونغوان يعني المخاوف الاوروبيون ايضا لهم
مخاوف لكن بيجين تستقبل المسؤولين
الامريكيين ولكن لا تستقبل مسؤولين
الاوروبيين جزء بوريل اوجلت زيارته بحجه
او كما جاء في المصادر
الرسميه الصينيه بانه في انتظار عباره في
انتظار ظروف افضل للزياره ما الذي يمنع
بجيل من استقبال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
اهلا ومرحبا بكم في الحقيقه الصين يعني
ترحب بالتواصل وتعاون مع جانب اوروبي
راينا هناك زياره
منذ عام الماضي المستشار الالماني وكذلك
الرئيس الفرنسي وكذلك رئيس رئيسه مفاوضيه
الاوروبيه وكذلك رئيس المجلس الاوروبي فهم
كله فقط
[موسيقى]
ترحب بزياره الممثل السياسي الخارجي
للاتحاد الاوروبي وفي وقت التي يناسب
الجانبين لم يمنعه يعني اي زياره وتتخذ
موقف انفتاح على التبادل والتواصل مع جانب
الاوروبي كما فعلت كذلك مع الجن الامريكي
فلذلك المخاوف وكذلك المخاوف الامريكيه
ليس هناك داعي لذلك لان كل هذه الاش
من اجل التوسيع الانفتاح وكذلك يعطي يعني
تماما قانونيا لانفتاح
حسينة الاكثر اعداله فاذا كان للشركات
الاجنبيه ليس لديها نيه لتجسس وللتجاره
الطبيعيه فيجب ان تدعم هذه
القانون لان هذا يعطيك
يعني
لزياده اعمالها وممارسات التجاره الطبيعيه
في الصين
نعم خلنا البعد الاوروبي ايضا في هذا
النقاش هل واشنطن تنسق مع الاوروبيين في
هذا السياق
نحن فعلا نعمل بتعاون وثيق مع الاوروبيين
فعلى سبيل المثال ما يتعلق بالقيود على
اشباه الموصلات وصناعتها
وهذه اشباه
ذات النوعيه العاليه يستخدمها الجيش
الصيني لدينا اتفاق مع هولندا في هذا
المجال ونتحاول مع اتحاد الاوروبي حول
مواضيع كثيره من ذلك قانون مكافحه
الجاسوسيه الجديد وايضا موقف الصين حول
اوكرانيا وبالتالي هناك تنسيق رائع بين
الولايات المتحده واوروبا وطبعا انا
مختلفه قليلا نحن نؤكد اكثر على التنافس
مع روسيا الى الصين بينما اوروبا تركز
اكثر على مجالات التعاون مع الصين بشكل
عام ما اعتقد ان الجانبين
توصله او اعتمادان الاراء بطريقه ايجابيه
جدا
الفرق هو في التنافس والتعاون مع الصين
دكتور زياد ماجد في ضوء كل هذه المعطيات
كيف تنظر الى مستقبل العلاقات الصينيه مع
الغرب على ضوء هذا التقارب
اظن ان هذه العلاقات ستبقى لفتره طويله
محل مراوحه بين
تمتينها اقتصاديا وايجاد اليات تعاون تعفي
العديد من الدول من منافسات ومن مخاوف ان
يبقى ميزان المدفوعات او ميزان التجاري
لصالح الصين سيكون هناك تعاون ومحاولات
لايجاد صياغ عبر منظمه التجاره العالميه
وغيرها من اسس التعاون المتبادل
لتخفيف الخلافات في هذا المجال لكن في نفس
الوقت سينكون هناك توتر وتنافس ان في
منطقه اسيا التي اصبحت استراتيجيه بالنسبه
لوشنطن او في العديد من المناطق يعني
الصين توقع اتفاقات مع البرازيل مع جنوب
افريقيا مع دول في حوض البحر المتوسط مثل
الجزائر المرفق في
الشرق المتوسط في اسرائيل هو ضمن مشاريع
التوسيع الصينيه على البحر الاحمر هناك
حضور صيني في السودان وفي غيرها اضافه الى
احتمالات تطوير العلاقات بين دول الخليج
العربي والصين وطبعا ايران والصين كل هذا
بالنسبه للغرب يؤكد ان الصين لم تكتفي
بدورها الاقتصادي كمارد اقتصادي يستطيع ان
يتفوق على منافسيه في بعض القطاعات انما
ايضا تريد ان تستثمر في ذلك سياسيا وهذا
بالطبع ستكون يعني نتيجته مواجهات
ومنافسات كما هي الحال عاده في العلاقات
الدوليه مع افضليه في بعض القطاعات للغرب
ستستمر مجالات التعليم والطبابه وبعض
القطاعات الشبيهه الاخرى وتفوق للصين في
قطاعات ثانيه اقتصادات تحويليه
والانتاج الواسع الذي يصدر الى اسواق
العالم نحن امام مرحله جديده لكن لا اظن
ان اختلافا جذريا على صعيد التنافس مع
الصين سيطرا عليها التنافس سيستمر ومعه
ايضا محاولات تقليص كل رقع التوتر يمكن ان
تنشا بانتظار ان تنتهي حرب اوكرانيا اذا
انتهت في يوم قريب من اجل ربما اعاده رسم
شكل اخر للعلاقات الدوليه وموازين القوى
فيها رغوان انت كيف ترى مستقبل هذه
العلاقات بين الصين والغرب
طبعا هذه العلاقه اذا يعني
هناك
السبع اسباب التواتر هناك بسبب ان هناك
حكم الخاطئه لتطور الصين من جبل الدول
الغربيه فسين تريد ان تدرك يعني
الولايات
الولايات المتحده عن التنميه الصينيه
وتطور الصين لا تشكل تحديا لها بل هي كذلك
تشكل يعني تعطي فرصه للتطور الولايات
المتحده كذلك فاذا يمكن السير في نفس
الاتجاه والتعاون يعني
المزيد من التعاون اراك موجود الخلافات
فهذه وكذلك التوقف عن محاولات الاحتوائي
سين لان كل الاعمال لاحتوائسين في نهايه
ادر بمصالح الامريكيه الشركات امريكيه ذلك
فاذا يمكن السير في نفس الاتجاه ويمكن
اعاده هذه العلاقه الصينيه الامريكيه الى
مسار التطور السليم فهذا يعني يسب لصالح
جميع الدول في العالم شكرا جزيلا لك رونجو
الاعلامي والكاتب الصيني كنت معنا
ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من نيويورك دينس وايلدر
مدير مجلس الامن القومي الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون الصين ونشكر ضيفنا من باريس الدكتور
زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس
والى هنا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]